the idea was that solving social
problems is different than solving
business problems it takes strategy it
takes research it takes careful analysis
but it also takes a different set of
tools and we saw a lot of terrific tools
being developed in the business context
to make companies competitive and
profitable and successful we didn't see
a similar set of tools being as widely
developed in the nonprofit sector and so
we wanted to create a firm that brought
the same kind of analysis and strategy
and reasoning and research into solving
social issues for foundations for
nonprofits and for corporations we often
deal with funders charitable funders
whether its foundations or private
foundations or corporate foundations or
even individual philanthropists and one
of the first barriers is the fact that
people don't really expect to solve
social problems through their
philanthropy they would like to pick a
good cause of worthy organization give
that organization money and that's a
great thing to do but there's a real
problem with our nonprofit sector today
in this country you know we have the
most vibrant most creative largest
nonprofit sector in the world and yet
when you look at where the United States
stands on social issues on things like
education things like health care things
like the environment we're at the bottom
of the list of developed countries so
somehow in the one hand we have this
wonderful nonprofit sector and on the
other hand we're not solving the
problems that the nonprofit sector is
supposed to be solving so there's a real
basic problem there and we believe the
problem really has to do with the
behavior of donors that donors are not
expecting or demanding results they
aren't being realistic and strategic in
their giving to actually try and solve
the problem and without that incentive
nonprofits respond to the way donors
think currently rather than focus in on
how can they actually achieve a
meaningful
first n courses there may not be an
organization that they should choose I
guess the best way to think about it is
we did a very interesting engagement for
the Gates Foundation and they came to us
and they said we'd like to help
encourage more effective philanthropy
not more money but more effective
practices but we're not really sure what
that means so what does it mean to be
effective in philanthropy and so they
asked us to go out and interview a
couple dozen donors high-net-worth
donors people who give away at least a
million dollars a year but people who
are perceived as being highly effective
in their philanthropy and to be honest
we didn't think this engagement was
going to work because we were talking to
all kinds of donors men women young old
inherited wealth real estate new
technology all across the country but we
actually found something very
interesting all of these donors came
into philanthropy they were responding
to requests they were being a good
citizen they didn't really see any
impact for their money they could give
away millions of dollars and nothing
seemed to change and they were kind of
discouraged and at some point they came
across an issue that had real urgency
and real personal significance to them
so in one case someone's son had a rare
brain disease and there wasn't much
research in another case there was a
beautiful theater downtown that was
going to be torn down as in development
and what happened was they stopped
thinking about how do I give away money
and they started thinking about how do I
solve a specific problem and it changed
completely how they went about things so
instead of saying which charity do I
write a check to or so on they said what
would have to happen for this problem to
be solved and how can we take
responsibility for making those things
happen and it's really this problem
solving approach to philanthropy that we
see is the core difference between
effective philanthropists and most of
the very well-meaning well-intentioned
people out there who give it away a lot
of money but aren't really signal
by travelpod member